the family spokesperson for the family
of Harry done up here with me starting
from the right we have Bruce Charles who
is Harry's second dad immediately to my
right is Charlotte Charles who is
Harry's mom immediately to my left is
Tim Dunn who is Harry's dad and on the
far left is Tracy Dunn who is Harry's
second month so let me just start off by
making a few brief remarks firstly it's
it's really good to be here in New York
and in the United States and we're
really glad to have the opportunity to
to share our story with with the people
of America because it's a terrible
terrible story of just desperate loss
and compounded by this poor family being
really abandoned by by the authorities
there's clearly been some significant
developments over the weekend which
happy to take any questions on on
Saturday I think it was although it's
time is blurring both governments seemed
to get to a place where they agreed
between them that and cyclists
no longer had immunity which was clearly
a significant development and also on
the same day I was pleased to have an
approach from a lawyer who had been
appointed on behalf of and cyclist so in
that said let's see we have what we have
until about 10:30 this morning happy to
go straight to questions I just opened a
dialogue with a lawyer at the moment
Lisa and certainly we will try she and I
to get together by the end of the week
but it's dependent on on her agreeing
and indicating that mrs. sue khulus will
return to the United Kingdom to present
herself to the police that's our that's
our condition and if that isn't
confirmed then we don't really see the
point in meeting so if that's
forthcoming I'll meet with their lawyer
hopefully Friday or Saturday but if not
I think we'll we it's a condition for us
we certainly plan to be in Washington
Wednesday and Thursday at the very least
we have reached out to a number of
lawmakers and politicians and as many of
us you know I've also reached out to
President Trump and I'll make myself
available to any politician who takes
interest in this terrible story then you
see these people here now these are just
humble normal ordinary people like you
and I from a tiny little community in
Northamptonshire in England and they
find themselves in the middle of a
really you know quite a quite a
hurricane but yeah we will be there
Wednesday and Thursday and I'll meet
with anybody who we need him to agree to
put her on a plane back to the UK
although having said that I believe that
she should be able to make that decision
herself she needs to just do the right
thing and just come back and face what
she's done face us as a broken family
face our UK system and just do the right
thing she needs to set an example to her
home children that you can't run away
when you've done something so terribly
wrong
we heard in a statement I have not heard
of waste
I don't know how sincere it was of
course she's suffering we've noticed all
along she would be suffering her
children must be suffering you know two
of them were in the car and that's
horrific
our dad wasn't a little lad the pile was
extremely damaged as well as hairy so
we're not inhumane we don't we still
don't wish her any ill harm but we need
to hear it from her in her own words in
a room on our terms in the UK with
therapists and whoever else around us
that we can help mediators but just
hearing it through a statement we're
seven weeks in now it's a bit too much
too little too late I'm afraid
not go home you know whoever made that
decision we do not know but we shouldn't
have gone through this we shouldn't be
suffering like this it should have been
an open-and-shut case
the evidence is extremely clear what
happened we've been told that there is
CCTV evidence showing her leaving RAF
Croton on the wrong side of the road and
that CCTV follows her all the way down
the road on the wrong side of the road
and you see Harry's head light of his
motorbike and then there's a big
fireball when his bike went up so it
should have been a clear-cut case it
should have been simple and I promised
Harry and we promised Harry as a family
when we lost him that night when we were
talking to him in the hospital and we'd
lost him already that we would make sure
justice was done we thought it would be
an easy one an easy case with all the
evidence that the Northamptonshire
police have but clearly not and that's
why we're here
we just want to know that she's being
brought back to the UK you know that
would be a huge step in than in the
right direction it's the only right
thing to do it's the only humane thing
to do and we would hope then that we can
try to start to move forward and UK
justice system do whatever they feel is
right because with it being seven weeks
later we're not sure if we can be
involved with trying to reduce her
sentence which is what we said we would
do in the first place they wanted to
pursue her or charged her with death by
dangerous driving we spoke to the police
right at the beginning knowing that she
had children we were going to work with
them ask for her sentence to be reduced
to death by careless and ask for a
suspended so that we could didn't take
her away from her children although
she's robbed us of one of ours it wasn't
unintentional it was an accident
we understand that but seven weeks on
and we've had to do this to get an
apology just in writing
I've always wanted to ask her if she
could explain the moment of the crash
find out if she comforted Harry if she
spoke to Harry find out what her
movements were did she try and call the
emergency services or I just I just
struggling because I can't imagine my
dad being in the ditch and not having
any comfort from anybody until the
ambulance and the police turn up X
minutes later when we had the funeral
which was a lovely tribute to him I
thought maybe that was the time we were
going to turn the corner but then it
wasn't until a week later when we found
out that she'd left the country and now
it feels like it's just gone right back
to that night he died and it's just no
way I could start grieving you as a
family we can't start we need need this
resolved we do need this resolved
in my opinion they knew she did have I'm
sorry but this so it's not right here
this is just somewhere somewhere
somebody's made a decision to give this
lady immunity and she's not entitled to
the immunity as things have been said
and we've known that from the start we
we knew from the start
they've made a mistake someone's made a
mistake just said to me it's so so
simple it's just on that night there was
an accident
a lady made a mistake she killed our son
she didn't mean to kill it she didn't
mean to have the accident but you cannot
walk away from that and just leave and
expect nothing to happen our boy died he
deserves to have some justice whatever
that says out to be oh you hear if your
son with child was to die you would want
justice for your child and that's all we
want we don't want you want justice we
want justice for Harry I would just say
to him as a man as a as a you know
father thank you just to see how it is
how could you let this happen if you
were a father and your child had died
surely you'd want that person to own up
and take the responsibility of their
actions
it's really not we have we have a range
of legal options open to us which we are
continually reviewing with with a a QC
who's been appointed on one of the top
solicitors in London so in that back
home we are we are we are thinking about
our strategies and wondering what to do
we are we are on the on the verge of
appointing a lawyer who has expertise in
international law and you know just
specifically these laws as well here on
this side I mean one of the reasons why
I'm here is to is to try and talk to
some lawyers who might be able to help
us with legal proceedings here in the
United States so you know are the people
on the other side of this dispute need
to understand that this family here are
determined to get justice for Harry
whatever that means and if we're you
know I've only been I was only came on
board about three weeks ago and it's
been a whirlwind ever since I think we
the the father of us here are going for
a world record of lis lack of sleep I
think I'm on my sixteenth day now of not
not being able to sleep because there's
just so much to do
so I've got a team of lawyers who are
sitting back in London at the moment
busy plotting this out and where is the
best way to go but you know we we will
get justice for Harry these little green
ribbons that you see which we are
wearing now symbolized Harry and it's a
very special thing that's happening
Harry loved
Kawasaki green that was his favorite
color and his motorbike the one that he
had his accident on was painted at
Kawasaki green so we wear these ribbons
today and we will continue to wear them
as a memory to this exceptional boy a
wonderful wonderful boy
smiling and happy good to everybody a
fantastic motorbike rider I'm not a
motorbike rotor but I've spoken to
people who know
he said he was 19 he was an incredibly
capable safe writer and you know apart
from that you know we are trying to
raise funds and we are selling these
ribbons to to to people in the community
back home
I think demand was you know incredible
we didn't think we I think we printed a
thousand but then they were gone in
minutes so you know we we are I think
the expression these days is a lawyer up
and I am not gonna rest until we secure
every last little bit of justice for
this young man because he would he
deserves nothing less he was taken from
us far too young in circumstances and
not of his making and I have committed
to my friends these are my friends
they're my neighbors and now I'm
representing them we were going to we
were going to pursue every single Avenue
on both sides of the Atlantic
that's absolutely right so then the
third phase of that once we've done that
is again I cannot tell you how wonderful
these people are who who are standing up
here with me the dignity and the
magnanimity and the decency I daresay if
it had been my child I'm not sure that I
could stand here is with the composure
that they are but one of the things that
is being become clear to us is just how
complicated these international
diplomatic immunity laws are there's
only three lawyers in the UK who really
truly understand them we have hired two
of them and they have both said that
unfortunately you know with Harry's
passing this is now an opportunity given
the conduct of the United States
government what they've done here this
is now an opportunity to get those laws
I'll get the dusty books out and get
some really serious brainy people and
say what happened to this family up here
is not good enough and in its simplest
terms what we have is you know clearly a
terrible accident but any of us in this
room or anybody watching out there in
the world I would like to thank you
would you would
run you would stand and face the
consequences and and work with the
authorities whatever the courts decided
I can't imagine that a single person
watching this and can comprehend the
actions that either the US government
took or the cyclist is when they got on
that plane and flew back home and what
were they thinking they knew they were
leaving of this family they didn't know
who they were
look these are normal people up here
with me they're you and I what would any
of us do
and you know God bless these people up
here they they are terrific people they
don't mean an cephalus any any ill-will
it was it was an accident but the
conduct afterwards has been nothing
short of disgraceful we don't know who
was involved in this decision or whether
mrs. cyclists left the UK of her own
free will
but we will not rest until we've either
had a chance to speak to those who made
that decision or had disclosure from
them through the courts because you know
these people deserve that explanation
they just imagine what we've been
through over the last few weeks and I
spent I've pretty much 24/7 with these
people and we sit there we scratch our
head thing that we always conduct is how
could thing how could they even forget
the law yeah human level or a molar
Bible look the pain that's been Carlos
on top of on top of the obvious grief
which those of us who have suffered loss
would know is bad enough and you get
that knock on the door he say she's gone
and you know you don't think you can get
justice for your son like Tim said you
know it's it was just that well I say a
kick in the stomach yeah Arthur
I think it's still you know it's still
some positivity for sure I think we'd
like the same letter from the US
government as opposed to just our own in
the UK just as double confirmation that
she does not have this immunity over and
above that feeling that you get in the
pit of your tummy every morning knowing
that you've lost a child there's been an
extra Naurang at us in our tummies since
we lost him
that just keeps telling us something's
not right and that's why I think call it
parental instinct what if I don't know I
can't we can't explain I can't explain
it but there's always been an extra
feeling that something's not right
I suppose the letter from Dominic rob
has confirmed in a sense that we have
been right all along that she doesn't
have the immunity but to hear it from
the US government as well would be a
bonus for us yeah we are literally
living hour by hour anyway have been for
the last seven weeks each day's rolling
into the next so to put a day-and-a-half
timeframe on it just seems relatively
short for us at the moment but we would
hope that we'll get something else
and when we had a meeting with Dominic
round last week and so yeah we had a
meeting with Dominic Robles last week
and it didn't go as I was hoping it was
he sort of said they asked for a waiver
a couple of times and the u.s. didn't
grant it and then we get a letter saying
that she didn't have immunity anyway so
I don't understand why they were asking
for a waiver then all the last week what
they you know to me just doesn't add up
why are you asking for something that
she doesn't have so it just yes he was
great when I got the letter I was
overjoyed but now a chance to think
about it it doesn't really change
anything hasn't really made any
difference to me because we always said
she didn't you know she didn't have
immunity it was just that they confirmed
it after they've asked for two or three
waivers I don't see how the government
can be or the forum and Cromwell office
can get it so different what is it I
don't know it may just looking at it too
simple or as it just seems like why ask
for a waiver admit she doesn't have
immunity dinner sorry